[Music]
guys if you're fans of the marvel
netflix shows i am so sorry i got some
real bad news for you but first do me a
favor hit subscribe turn on
notifications i am doing this every day
let's get started
it looks like the marvel netflix era is
officially over shows like daredevil
jessica jones iron fist luke cage the
punisher and the team-up series the
defenders are all leaving the platform
at the end of this month
it looks like the rights to these
projects are reverting back to disney as
netflix's license has ended though
disney has not made any announcements
regarding premiere dates it looks like
disney is kind of staying quiet on this
one this all started when fans started
noticing at the beginning of the shows
it was saying it would no longer be
available after march 1st and i guess
this pretty much means it's officially
over if you don't remember it actually
all started in 2015 when marvel actually
allowed netflix to make these shows
first we had daredevil with charlie cox
then we had jessica jones with kristen
ritter luke cage iron fist and then a
big fan favorite the punisher originally
the deal was struck between disney which
owned marvel studios and netflix to
expand the scope of the mcu with
multiple series that were connected to
the movie all the shows however were
abruptly cancelled starting in 2018 as
disney shifted its focus to developing
its own marvel shows for disney plus's
streaming platform again in 2018 we all
assumed that we would not see these
characters again either in the mcu in a
while or at all but then we had this
huge surprise with kingpin actually
arriving in hawkeye which blew everyone
away it was one of those big cameos that
i know everyone was excited for just
because i know there were so many fans
for the original daredevil series i
personally was too and let me tell you i
was blown away
as well as seeing charlie cox come out
in spiderman no way home let me tell you
that right there was something that was
rumored for a while i personally didn't
believe it because it just seemed too
crazy of an idea and guess what we
actually got it and i'm honestly gonna
owe that one to the fans because it
looks like them pushing it online on
twitter on instagram everything
to bring back daredevil
and it looks like marvel was actually
listening to us for now i hope that we
see the defenders down the line in the
mcu i think they deserve it uh if you
haven't already do me a favor please
subscribe turn on notifications i am
doing this every day
and i'll see you tomorrow